I'd like to introduce Jan he's coming to
us from uh Stanford and he's going to
talk to us about uh the python
integrated query language socialite
social hi so a little bit about the name
socialite so initially we focused on um
large scale social network analysis
hence the name social light uh later we
extended it to uh so that it can be
applied to Big Data analysis machine
learning in general so so it's python
integ qu quy language for Big Data
analysis
now so why do we need another big data
analysis platform right there are tons
of Big Data analysis platform well
that's because the existing uh Big Data
analysis platforms have problems well
most of them are very hard to use even
for experienced programmers because
um they only provide very low level
Primitives and also most many of them
are very uh inefficient because they are
not designed to fully utilize the
network bandwidth and in my opinion most
uh distributed applications distributed
um data analysis applications uh they
should be uh Network ion
bound and on top of that um if you need
to do slight just slightly different
tasks uh you need to learn to to use
different Frameworks for example if you
want to do graph analysis you need to
learn to use a framework A1 for data
mining maybe A2 and for relation you
need to run another um framework that's
a lot of effort
um that's why we came up with uh uh the
project socialite it's a high level
query language uh that is very easy and
very efficient the high level we provide
high high level Primitives and the high
level queries are compil down to very
optimized parallel and
disord and the compile code is very
optim very optimized uh up to a thousand
times faster than equivalent hard
program if you run it on a um uh infin
band network if you run it on 10 GB
Internet it's somewhere between 100
times faster and a thousand times faster
so in between uh and also it of course
it's python integrated actually is
jython and this one thing is good for
Gra
Data Mining and relational
ques so with that I'd like to give you a
quick outline of the talk so first I'm
going to uh uh discuss the programming
Concepts in Social light uh distributed
tables um socialite rules and is python
integration and I'm going to give you uh
an overview of the socialized system and
then I will go over some of the analysis
algorithms some of them are um graph
algorithms some of them are um data
mining algorithms and then I'm going to
give you evalation
numbers and if time permits I will give
you a very quick demo
okay distributed inmemory tables are
primary data structure in socialite to
store user data it's a column oriented
storage so the items in the same column
are continuously continuously uh stored
in
memory uh you can use this uh kind of uh
syntax to to declare or Define a a
socialized table first you write the
name of the table followed by um column
declarations and the type of the column
can be primitive types int long FL
double and it can be also um object
types string or usual defin
types let me give you an actual specific
example of uh social tables so here we
have four table declarations uh the
first one uh uh here
declares a table named F having two in
columns and an example of this food
table would be something like this where
we have four
TS here we have another food table uh
with added parenthesis in the second
column meaning that the second column is
nested and the same set of TS on the
left hand side will be uh represented in
this way so it's kind of like the
adjacency list so it's it comes in handy
when you store um uh graphs for
example uh the third one here with the
added angular bracket it declares a dist
table where we partition the table with
respect to the value of this uh what's
called partitioning column with this uh
angular bracket here and an example of
this bar table would be something like
this if we happen to have uh two
machines
then the bar table is partitioned into
two and Stor across these two
machines uh the last one uh has zero do
10 uh in addition to the angular
bracket uh it uh it's basically called a
range operator z. 10 is range operator
and you indicate that the value of that
column is within that
range uh if you have that range operator
we apply range based partitioning range
based partitioning uh where the two
pools whose First Column value is
between 0 to five are stored in machine
one if you have two machines and two
pools um whose first count value is 6 to
10 are stored in machine two like this
so compare it with the that other one
over there where we applied hash B hash
based partitioning
okay um we Al we also make it possible
to um
uh for users to control the structure of
the tables a little bit uh for example
you can add indexing to a particular
column or you can sort a column or we
can declare that this table is multi
multi set meaning that you can have the
same equivalent tles multiple times
okay so once you declare tables or
distribute table like that you can use
um what we call social light rules to
apply to process the data and apply for
example relational
operations so an example of social rule
is uh something like this where we
uh uh what's on the left hand side of
colon dash is called Rule head and
what's on the right hand side of colon
dash is Rule Body so basically what we
are doing here is we are um joining the
tables in the rule body and storing the
result into the table in the rule head
so let me give you a specific example
here so let's say that we have have uh
before we execute this R we have these
five tles in bar table and these five
tles in clo table and F is empty before
we execute this fool then we go over the
two pools in Bart
table uh and for each T in B table we go
over TS in qu table and try to find
matching to P where the second column of
bar table matches the First Column of
the clo table uh because we use the same
variable name uh here same variable name
B uh well same variable name B uh in the
second column of B table and the First
Column of qu table so for this very
first TP here we have two matching TPL
in Co table here so we store the The
Joint result of the joint operation into
the full table and we have one more
matching toool here so after we evaluate
this rule we have uh three TOS in Full
Table
okay
um if you have a constant value instead
of Val valuable name in one in the
columns that means that we want you want
to select the TS uh whose uh that column
value is that constant so basically you
select those two pools with uh in this
case whose First Column value is one and
then do the Jo
operation uh let's have another look at
this example here uh because these
tables are distributed tables
um and assuming we have two machines
these tables are partitioned and stored
across these two machines uh for this uh
tle in B table uh to do the joint
operation we have matching too uh in
machine two so for that we need to send
this too
across across the machine and then do
the join operation and then uh Shi the
to back to where it should be stored uh
automatically and store it in the put in
the right partition in the full table so
we do that
automatically and uh of course we
accumulate some number of two pools in a
temporary table and transfer the entire
uh table as a single message and we try
our best to uh pipeline the computation
and this communication uh and uh so that
you can fully utilize the all the CPU
and uh Network uh band WID as well um so
if you use Infinity band network uh if
you use 10 GB internet we fully utilize
the entire the total bandwidth if you
use um Infinity band which gives you
about uh 5 GB uh per second we utilize
about up to uh 2 G uh per second which
is much better than any other uh
distributed platform uh distributed data
analysis platform okay um
okay
so
we the triple transfer is kind of
determined by the order of
tables so here in the previous case we
have bar table first and then quo table
next so in that case we try to ship the
Tule in bar table to where the matching
Tu in qu table are located but if you
have reversed if you reverse it and have
quo table first and then bar table next
then we try to ship the uh T in qux
Table to where the matching T in bar
table should be located uh uh for the
joint
operation so let's go back to the
previous example where for the T in B
table a comma B the matching too in Cox
table uh which is uh B comm c uh we know
the where the matching Tes in qu tables
qu table are located because we know the
value of B which is in the partitioning
column of quo table but if you reverse
these two and have quo table first then
for the T in c table we do not know
where the matching T in bar table should
be because we do not know the value of
uh a variable so in that in that case we
need to distribute uh broadcast the T in
c table to the rest of the machines
depending on the relative size of the
tables uh this may be better or worse
than the previous case and we believe
that this is the relative size of the
table is something that programmers are
typically aware of uh so we at the
moment we let the programmers to uh
control this uh Tri transfer with the uh
the table
order but uh potentially it's possible
for social runtime system to detect the
relative size of the tables and the
location of the uh partitions uh to
optimize this uh and minimize the
communication volume
okay um so let me use the same query
here to uh describe how we do the
parallel evaluation okay uh so let's say
that we have two machines and then bar
table is partition into two but each
partition in each machine is further
divided into to uh sub
partitions and uh for each T each uh
query like that which each rule like
that we take the uh the first table in
the rule body and create tasks uh
multiple tasks as many as the number of
uh uh sub
partitions and
uh uh exuse those tasks uh in multiple
course for example for this uh
uh socialite rule here uh since there
are four uh sub partitions in each of
the machine so we create four uh tasks
in each machine and these tasks are of
course parall exed by multiple
cores uh and if the uh synchronization
synchronization is needed then we
automatically add that and uh so that
you don't need to worry about that okay
and this the same query uh uh if you run
it on a single machine it uh is uh
optimized to use multiple cores and if
you run it on a cluster of machines and
it's the query is it distributed and
utilize all the machines
automatically uh and of course we
support aggregate operations uh and the
way how you use aggregate operations in
talite is by using this aggregate
function in the rule hat like that uh
and here the semantic is uh that you we
first apply the group by operation Group
by the value of the First Column the
preceding columns that uh are before the
the agre function and then we apply the
agre function to the applied column in
this case to the second
column so for for example uh in the same
uh uh say we have the same kind of T
puts in bar and quo table and uh after
we do the joint operation and before we
apply the aggregate function uh we have
the those three two pools and then we
apply the group by operation grouping by
the two Pools by the value of the First
Column and we in the first group we have
those two TOs and in the second group we
have this uh this to and then we apply
the mean operation and then after
the after we apply the AG function we
have uh just two t over
there
um we have buil-in aggregate functions
for common aggregation aggregate
operations for example mean Max sum
average and argument we also make it
possible for users to uh Define their
own uh agre functions either in Java or
Python and let me talk about the python
integration so these queries that you
you've just seen can be integrated into
uh python code a little bit similar to
uh link Q if you guys are familiar with
link Q in in C where you can integrate
the SQL like queries in inside C code
this is kind of similar so you can
integrate the social like queries in
Python code and the python code is
sequentially acced and the social
queries are either acced in parallel or
in distributed
cluster and the queries need to be
inside the backtick so that we know that
this is a social query not a python
code uh and there is kind of full inte
interoperation between Python code and
social queries
um so from social like queries you can
access python functions and python
variables and also from socialite from
python code you can access the two pools
in the uh python in the social queries
let me give you an
example so here we have uh python code
printing out just a single sentence and
then we can you can mix social like
query in the in the same file within
this btic and here we have declared add
a social like table named F and inserted
a single T into the full
table and then here we have defined a
python variable V and we are accessing
that python variable inside the social
query here and the preceding data sign
indicates that this is from either
python or Java
world and we also make it possible to
use uh python functions in Social Li
queries like that
uh but for the functions we ask you to
annotate this return type so that we can
apply
optimizations and finally we you can use
uh python for Loop like this to iterate
over the two pools in the uh in the
social table so if the if the table is
stored distributed uh in the cluster we
fetch the two pools uh where this uh
script is executed uh so that to make it
easy for you to uh interact with social
tables so a little bit about so that was
uh actually we we were using chyon so
it's integrated into jython not cpython
so you uh at the moment you cannot use
uh say so for example um NPI or sipai or
pandas but there is this
uh this project called J and I jython
native interface which is by this guy uh
Stefan and they are trying to make make
it possible make python C extensions to
be accessed from jython code so they got
to the point where um you can run uh TK
inter inter in in uh jyon so the next
step is to make nonp available in in
jyon so with that integration uh you can
use uh cpython extensions in Social
queries as
well okay this is very high level
overview of social system so we have
workers and master worker worker node
actually execute those queries and the
master node uh for example compiles the
query into uh Java by code and optimizes
it uh and initiates the query
execution and we support hadu uh distri
file system uh so we make it possible
for social to read uh data from hdfs and
write data to hdfs as well as well and
we also use hdfs to store for the for
checkpointing and resuming okay for the
for
tolerance well these are a few system
component um uh the master node has the
compiler and the worker node has um test
scheduler and um worker thread and
network thread and these are a few um
important optimizations that we applied
in the system I'm not going to the
details but uh well for example what
what was important was was our custom
memory worker which reduced the G
garbage collection run time
significantly and also we use a direct
bite proper for the uh network data and
if you use direct B bite perer Java jbm
tries it best to uh reduce I mean remove
the uh zero copy so that um the network
API directly accesses the data in in
this direct B for
uh with that let me go over some of the
analysis algorithms implemented in
social life
so some of these are graph algorithms
for example shortest path or page Rank
and others are data mining algorithms
kin or logistic
regression so here we have uh social
light query implementing show this path
algorithm so we have two tables declared
Edge table and path table that table
just stores the graph itself Source node
Target node and the edge length and the
pest Table stores is going to store the
result of this uh shortest path
algorithm where for each node in the
graph it's going to store the the
shortest path from The Source node to
that
node uh and with these
two uh lines of social query we
implemented social uh social path
algorithm it has two rule bodies which
is kind of new to uh you guys the
semantic of having multiple Rule Body is
applying that aggregate function to the
both rule bodies so the AGG function is
applied to all the TS from Rule Body one
as well as Rule Body two and here we are
using recursive query here uh it's
recursive query because uh the table in
the rad is same as the table in the rule
body and uh well let's go over the first
guy here the first
uh this Rule Body here is the base case
of the uh recursion where you're saying
that uh the the shortest distance to the
source node uh T is zero of course and
that is uh inserted into the path table
and that triggers this recursive part
where uh for
that for that t we are going over the
edges of that Source node and trying to
update try to update the distance
shortest distance to the those neighbor
node uh uh by the uh shortest pass to
the that Source node uh by adding the
adding that with the the the the edge
length and if that uh actually updated
the pass table if that was like smaller
than the previous uh shortest distance
then it's going to trigger another
recursion here and that is repeated
until uh it reaches fixed point point or
in other words uh there's no changes to
the path
table um because of the nature of this
mean agre function we can optimize this
uh query to use D algorithm if it runs
on a single machine with single core or
we can apply we can turn this into uh
what's called parallel data stepping
algorithm which is fastest parallel
shortage path
algorithm uh and that's the way the
reason why we can apply those
optimization is because of the nature of
that uh uh AG function there and if
you're interested you can uh look up our
papers here just search with uh
socialite and and my name G1 and you're
going to have a few papers which
describes uh some of the theoretic
background uh and this is Page rank
implemented in in Social liquer and the
very first one uh in Orange initializes
the page rank value for each node uh
where the initialized value is one over
the number of uh
node and in in this for Loop here we are
trying to update the page rank value of
of node Pi at iteration T1 t+1 using the
uh
uh pank value Pi of uh PJ at iteration T
so I'm not going going to go into the
details but uh let's compare this with
the uh Wikipedia description of the
algorithm where here we are initializing
the pagent value which maps to that
orange guy and here this equation is to
update the the page rank value at
iteration t t + one uh for node Pi using
node Pi's uh patient value at iteration
T which
very naturally maps to the in my opinion
maps to this social query where this
constant part uh maps to the first guy
red one over there where we are using
the damping P Factor uh
0.85 and this second part maps to uh
the uh the green one over there notice
that this is although we use the same
table name rank over there this is not a
recursive quy because we are
uh updating the values at t+ one using
the value uh at T So this cannot trigger
the recursion here
okay so that was a pank
algorithm and let's go over some of the
data mining
algorithms so cins is uh clustering
algorithm given uh a set of data points
you are uh grouping those data Point
into K groups right uh and the way how
they apply this algorithm is basically
you um initially you randomly assign the
data points into different uh groups and
then at each iteration you're kind of
refining the the groups uh the assigned
groups such that for each center of the
data point you are um uh you're updating
the centers such that it's average of
the data points values uh who uh is
assigned to that cluster and after that
with the updated Center uh you
reassigning the data points to the
closest um centers okay and
you're uh you're doing it again and
again until there's no changes to the uh
to the cluster but here we I'm just
iterating over 50 times in which case it
usually um um stabilized so here the
first query here is updating the
the uh the
center by averaging the data points
using that average um AG function and
the second guy uh the the green query
green guy here uh reassigns the data
points to the closest um Center using
this Argin um AG function and with this
two uh two socialite rules you implement
uh came the clustering algorithm and
this uh runs on a cluster machines if
you run it on a cluster machine this
runs on a multical machine single
multical machine if if if that's what
you
have uh logistic regression is kind of
similar I'm not going to details but you
need a few more uh social life functions
for DOT back sum uh which are basically
uh doing some Vector operations vectors
Vector product or vector sum or uh for
this sigmoid function but basically it's
very similar
and with these two lines of code ques
you implemented logistic Iration
algorithm distribut logistic Iration
algorithm uh so now let me give you some
evalation
number so we did three sets of
evaluation to evaluate social on single
machines having single core and also uh
evate the socialized queries on
multicore machine and dis
machines and here's the result so this
is for the single single core
performance and for this we compared
social light with Java and for the and
we implemented these six graph
algorithms in um in Java as well as
social light and for Java we implemented
once and then we later we
optimized we we spend a few more hours
to optimize it and this is optimize Java
and socialite against uh unoptimized
Java so this is how these are faster
than uh unoptimized Java
so so basically here this says that uh
optimize uh this white one is Java and
this red one is socialite and this says
that Java and socialize about 1.6 times
faster than uh kind of unoptimized java
and you can see see that t is very close
to highly optimized Java uh
implementation so that's single code
performance and this is how it SC scales
uh over 1 to 16 cores that's single
machine having 16 cores and the red guy
here is the scalability
and the blue line here is the execution
time for these
guys it SK SC is very
very well uh it's kind of the nature of
the algorithm for shortest pass it
scales wors but that's very close to uh
optimal the so with 16 cores is a little
better than uh 10 times faster than
single
core uh but the Optima is about with 16
cores is about 12 to 13 times faster
than single core but it's very close to
the
optimal for distributed uh evaluation we
worked with Intel and compared a few uh
existing data analys well graph analysis
and data analysis um Frameworks uh we
compared Comm blah which is a distrib um
linear algebra
Library uh we also compared graphlab uh
graph based machine learning uh
framework and socialite as well as jff
which is an open source implementation
of pral and Intel people went on to
implement native uh implementation for
these algorithms applying all the
possible optimizations including some of
the uh algorithm specific optimizations
so that's native there and for this we
Implement four algorithms BFS page rank
collaborative filtering and triang
Counting
triangle and here we apply we used a
weak scaling model where uh as you
double the number of uh machines uh in
the computation we double the input data
size okay and here you can see that the
native uh implementation by Intel people
uh which is uh light blue here is
fastest in all
cases uh that's expected because that's
optimal and social light is uh very
close to Optimal uh for triangle
counting and um social is a little bit
off for BFS and Page rank compared to
com and here we are uh pretty close to
compa um the Orion coma is very fast
it's implemented in C and um does some
optimizations but the reason why here in
these two algorithms where why why is
especially fast is for these two
algorithms uh they have the
implementation of these algorithms in
their Library so it's just a function
call there so int people did not you uh
did not use The Primitives to implement
those algorithm but just use that
function so here we actually implement
the algorithm in comat blah using the
the apis and here the we are closer to
uh comut BL in
performance uh we are faster than
graphlab in all cases uh even though the
graph flab have imp uh is implement Ed
in
C++ um and we are far better than uh uh
draff which is open source version preal
in in uh
Ado so that was the distribut
performance and I think I have time for
very quick demo so here in this demo I'm
going to go over scrape the uh Pi data
uh uh file to get the talks p p data the
title of the talks and then uh count the
the the words in the uh in the talk
titles okay
so here we have a socialite uh shell
which is basically python shell extended
to to run social queries so you can just
uh
use uh any python uh python command or
anything
here okay and here here in in this other
window I have
implemented a function that scrapes
the uh the talk titles from PI data
homepage and here we I used
a a generator function here where which
ELD the the titles every time you call
this function okay so I'm going to run
this
code
and
so it's going to fetch the title and it
shows the title here right and I'm going
to use this function in the social
query except that I'm going to Define
one more function and then I'm going
to declare a socialized table named
title which is going to hold the titles
talk titles uh using that uh function
there get title which uh uses URL liap
to uh to get the data get the title
net so in the very first well
okay so it says
finished
and so these are the titles P data title
to talk titles and I'm going
to Define another table which is going
to to store
the uh word counting okay so which
basically goes over the
titles and using this buil-in function
to split the the title by uh White space
and iterates all those words and for
each words uh I'm going to increment it
increment the the frequency by
one so let me go over the the word table
and see which ones are which words are
kind of
popular
uhoh
oops let
me
uh let me run it
again I'm going to grab the entire thing
and run it
again so initially it takes some time to
import
the
okay
she so here we have a word and Counting
whose counting is larger than three so
here we have a few what should I mean
stop wordss and of course we have a lot
of data mentioned python as well but
what's interesting is uh there are four
talks uh about either using Psy I guess
or about the psy itself
so
so these are those uh those titles so
these are those talks so you can see
that using social like query and uh
mixing it with python it's easy to uh
very easy to do some analysis and here
I'm I'm running this on my laptop but
you can imagine that uh running it on a
cluster it's just basically the same the
very same process
okay so that was the demo and
well so here's the summary social is a
dis requ language and it's very easy and
very
fast up to a thousand times faster than
Hado and it has very nice integration
with python and we have implemented a
few algorithms in uh social light uh and
this performance is very competitive and
if you're interested you can go to this
website here uh social. stanford.edu uh
to try it out uh the binary is already
there uh I'm going to unload the source
code uh to the G Gib repository uh this
coming week so if you're interested you
can also have a look at the code okay
that's it thank
you to have time for
questions
Senator um I may have missed this but um
I was wondering how does this system
compareed to other inmemory systems like
you know rdds from the amp lab uh like
what like rdd so spark the spark stack
and things like that uh I think spark
ldd is a little bit lower level than
social light so we the kind of uh
programming interface in Social uh
social light is in my opinion much more
high level than uh spark ldd but we are
limited by the memory size whereas I
think LED they have uh kind of spilled
the data into diss right um so it's
potentially possible for socialite to
use um uh spark rdd as one of the back
end uh for s for some
tables uh and besides that for the
performance uh we don't have direct
comparion of social light with uh
spark uh but we have compared uh
socialite with graphlab and graphlab has
compared theirs with spark and
in uh 2012 I think 12 13 osdi paper uh
gra people said that they're uh much
faster than spark and we are slightly
faster than graph so I think probably
it's a little bit faster uh but I think
what's more important is the the the the
F section level is
different other
questions
so if you're interested please go to
this website and uh have a look at
it can we give him a
hand thank
you okay you get a small break grab some
snacks go to the bathroom we have one
more talk and then we have uh after the
talk we have another keynote at the very
end um
I'm spacing his name and I know him
Peter Wang is going to be giving a nice
talk as the final keynote and after that
we are going to be having lightning
talks and they're going to be in the
same room that we'll see the final um
keynote in so run to the bathroom get
something to
drink iide myself see heart
is I see my r